they survived Saturday's truck bomb
blast in Mogadishu but sustained some of
the worst injuries
now some victims have been airlifted to
better equipped hospitals in turkey
clinics and hospitals in Mogadishu are
struggling to cope with the dozens of
wounded from the time the explosion
occurred up until now the government
leaders have been working hard to
provide the services needed by those
injured in the explosion it's now
possible for us to airlift 16 of some of
the seriously injured in the attack 12
brothers and Turkey a truck loaded with
explosives was detonated at a security
checkpoint in the capital Somalis
president is blaming the armed group
al-shabaab and Mohammed Abdullah for
Maggio's vow in the country won't be
demoralized by the attack which caused
the highest number of casualties in two
years the magnitude of the damage caused
by the blast led the prime minister of
Somalia to request assistance with the
Turkish government to provide treatment
to those injured in the attack a Turkish
military transporter landed with
much-needed supplies and medical staff
some was dated treat patients at a
Turkish Iran hospital in Mogadishu as
Turkey seeks to boost its influence in
the Horn of Africa it's been an
increasingly important aid donor
especially since the Somali famine in
2011 as more aid arise and the badly
injured leave the country is on edge
Somalis constantly wondering when and
where the next attack will be harder
Matassa al Jazeera